Thank you so much for having me! I threw
out my script too just because I feel
like everything that I started writing
out everyone was already saying in this
room so I'll just start with I used to
be a scientist for seven years. I did a
lot of excavations out in Spain where
once every month we would open the doors
towards the end of the term to be able
to invite communities from outside
families to spend their Sunday just like
watching archeologist, paleontologists,
geologists, paleoanthropologists working
together sort of like a human zoo. And
there was one time early on in my
SciComm career where I was still a
scientist, I hadn't been trained in
science communication at that time, where
I decided well actually the director was
like oh I have two foreigners who you
know speak Spanish well enough so
they'll lead the tour for everybody else.
I was really nervous because
obviously I didn't have the right kind
of training to be able to properly
translate why our research matters to
the people that are coming in, who are
people from Madrid families from
neighboring small towns and so I'm going
through the first field site and this
wonderful multi-generational family of
grandparents, little grandchildren
running around, and their parents came
with me.
And as I'm talking about one of the
field sites the old man with the cane
comes up to me and he's just like "okay
pero porque me quitandes todo este de
mis memorias? Why are you taking away
all of my memories? I grew up in this
town and all you're doing is digging
away the hills that my children should
be playing with that, my grandchildren
should be playing in" and I don't know
about you but I'm a Filipino
so to have a descendent of my colonizers
who had 300 years erased our culture
from the indigenous indigenous people in
my country to then ask me how it feels
to have their culture taken away.
I'm sorry was my answer because my
answer was tied to sympathy and empathy
and I was also so aware that I'm not the
right person to be talking to you about
why our research is destructive but is
valuable for you as well.
That was my privilege and that was my
own awareness of ok for this moment
I can at least open the discussion to
beyond these are the benefits that
you're getting from doing research in
your country in your background in your
backyard. Even though we're destroying it
I can at least talk to you about the
true nature of science inquiry. But yes
so much of it has been destructive and a
lot of it tied to people of color, to
minorities, to people who've been
oppressed for years. J Marion Sims and
gynecology and the history of torturing
black slaves to be able to benefit the
progress of science right? But you don't
often get a chance to share that and so
in that moment I turned it into a
conversation about the process of
science because that's what he needed. He
didn't need me to tell him that what we
were doing was somehow beneficial
because these things are the things that
we were finding are gonna end up in
their Museum and so that's my first
example of really actively listening to
the people that you're supposed to be
doing science outreach for. Whether or
not they're the community that you're
going to in their spaces just because
you as a person go into a new space
doesn't mean you're actually connecting
with them and I see this time and again
over and over.
You see scientists who you know need
different ways to be able to get to a
point where they are adaptable enough no
matter who they're talking to just get
thrown into a new space that they're not
prepared for and then end up giving the
speech or the lecture that they've just
prepared without being able to
truly listen to the people in front of
them and it's a missed opportunity to be
able to build back and forth. The
difference between what people think
about what dialogue is where you're kind
of just talking and letting people ask
questions is not the same as you as a
person in power asking and conversing
with the other person on the other side
and actually wanting to learn from them
I kind of wonder how many people in the
room who have job opportunities, funding
opportunities, opportunities for someone
to do outreach with your people actually
ask the people in the communities that
you're gonna do it for so your target
audience do any how many people actually
involve them in the creation of the
content that you're in the structure
that you're making? Great, mostly women.
And I have to say too that like I kind
of wish that I had the adaptable
training like I as someone who used to
be a scientist is now a science
communicator but also heavily dabbles in
comedy both in improv and standup
outside of my silos of academia I have
learned so much more from people outside
with similar problems than I have in
academia trying to solve the science
outreach questions that I keep asking
especially tied to diversity and
inclusivity. It's so important to get
out of those spaces because sometimes
the solution to your problem someone
else is already asking somewhere else
and finding a solution for but we keep
finding ourselves in the same circles of
work where you're only tapping into the
network that you're aware of instead of
maybe asking the other diverse people in
the room you I know you I know you so
well that I know there might be someone
else in your community outside of the
sciences, the academia, outside of science
outreach practitioning that would be
beneficial for this. So my example would
be the queer attraction lab that
I produced for guerrilla science,
specifically for a diverse group of
queer folk and I structured it so that I
knew I had a barrier to being able to
put this up because I needed to gain the
trust of queer people so that means I'm
not the right person to be standing in
front of those people to tell them this
is how science applies to your dating
and love lives especially when so much
of science have erased them from
research right. So I structured it so
that the first event that I ran was a
hetero version of attraction lab that
was split into two parts: one section was
for the daters, another section was for
any couple or someone who brings in
their partner and even though the idea
was that we were bringing in a hetero
community so many of the couples and
partners that were in that space where
queer folk who were like this is amazing,
this completely applies to me and I
would love to have one that's just for
the community and then I took those
learnings and built it to the next one
so that I knew that my my hosts and my
scientists had to be queer people. So I
ended up having two trans folk who knew how to speak to their community and who knew exactly
how the science goes into everyone's
everyday lives in a way that they're not
aware of. But likewise it also opened it
up to the painful conversation of why
people who are asexual aren't even
studied and researched so do they even
exist in science? People who don't
normally get and you know get questions
asked about them and so it opened the
conversation more beyond just how sexy
and fun science can be for everybody but
also how the scientific inquiry can be
changed if more diverse people can be in
it and that anyone can also apply it to
their lives. Time? Okay that's my time.
Anybody? Oh sorry.
Hi! My name is Helen Chang. I'm from New York
Sea Grant and I had a question about
that was a great presentation I really
enjoyed it. I had a question posed to all
the present presenters. So I feel like a
lot of people are really ingrained in
their ways and their behaviors and so
there's this wall of distrust especially
towards the science community and I
wonder how we can sort of break down
those walls so that this trust is
reestablished and that there that
science is you know a trusted source.
The people who run focus groups, do you
train up your facilitators to recognize
when people start using their power over
other speakers so that you can lessen
that whole idea of I'm the expert and
then you know just listen to me because
I have the answers to what you're saying
or you know are trying to recognize in
those moments where you're creating a
space for true communication between
people with different powers knowledge
bases where you can convince the experts
in the room that like lay persons
are also experts in a way that involve
their you know they inform their own
research because those moments are easy
to do on a one-on-one especially if
you've trained yourself enough to be
aware of your own biases and your own
privilege right? At least in my
personal experience for example at
guerrilla science I'm really great for
grateful for someone like Marc who's my
boss who in a space where producers are
pitching ideas he sees my face start to
crunch up because I don't notice it but
it's a gut reaction for me as a person
of color being like ooh that sounds so
not good and then encouraging me enough
to be like your voice matters you know
share it share why share why you're
feeling so uncomfortable right now. So I
don't know any of the other presenters.
I was just gonna follow up on that; do
you have examples of that type of
training that we can seek out or places
where it's publicly available or if you
guys have it is it publicly available at
all?
For facilitators you mean? Well I did my
masters in science communication and
public engagement at the University of
Edinburgh and there is a Beltane network
that provides training for scientists,
for science policymakers to be better
able to build community facilitation
events like that and they have published
a couple of PDFs and books that I could
share with you tied to how to create
those spaces so that you actually build
understanding and it also defines the
differences between things like you know
the benefits and the pros and cons of
what dialogue is, what debate does, what
deliberation does from a social science
perspective.